Witaj ponownie w kursie „Zrozumieć informację i obliczenia kwantowe". Mam na imię John Watrous i jestem dyrektorem technicznym ds. edukacji w IBM
Quantum. To jest 16. i ostatnia lekcja serii, a jej tematem jest kwantowe obliczanie odporne na
błędy. W trakcie trzech poprzednich lekcji widzieliśmy kilka przykładów kwantowych kodów korekcji błędów, które potrafią wykrywać błędy kwantowe i pozwalają nam je
korygować, o ile nie pojawia się ich zbyt wiele. Jeśli jednak chcemy wykorzystać korekcję błędów w obliczeniach kwantowych, wciąż pozostaje wiele
kwestii do rozwiązania – między innymi fakt, że nasze kwantowe gate'y, pomiary i preparacje stanów
same w sobie prawdopodobnie będą niedoskonałe. Na przykład, jeśli mamy przeprowadzić korekcję błędów na jednym
lub więcej qubitach zakodowanych przy użyciu kwantowego kodu korekcji błędów, będziemy musieli to zrobić za pomocą gate'ów i pomiarów, które same w sobie
mają pewną szansę na nieprawidłowe działanie. A to oznacza nie tylko nieudane wykrywanie czy korygowanie błędów, ale też możliwość
wprowadzania nowych błędów. Dodatkowo musimy wykonywać właściwe obliczenia, którymi jesteśmy zainteresowani – ponownie za pomocą gate'ów, które nie są
doskonałe. Na pewno nie możemy sobie pozwolić na dekodowanie informacji kwantowej w celu wykonania obliczeń, a następnie
ponowne kodowanie po ich zakończeniu, ponieważ błędy mogą wystąpić wtedy, gdy ochrona kwantowego kodu korekcji błędów jest nieobecna.
Oznacza to, że musimy opracować sposób wykonywania kwantowych gate'ów bezpośrednio na logicznych qubitach, które nigdy nie są pozbawione
ochrony kwantowego kodu korekcji błędów. To trudne zadanie, ale wiadomo, że o ile poziom szumów
spadnie poniżej pewnej wartości progowej, to w istocie możliwe jest wykonywanie arbitralnie dużych obliczeń kwantowych w sposób niezawodny przy użyciu zaszumionego sprzętu – przynajmniej
w teorii. Omówimy ten kluczowy fakt w dalszej części lekcji. Oto krótki przegląd
lekcji. Zaczniemy od podstawowego modelu kwantowego obliczania odpornego na błędy, w tym krótkiej dyskusji
na temat modeli szumów oraz ogólnej metodologii implementowania kwantowego circuit w sposób odporny
na błędy. Następnie przejdziemy do kwestii propagacji błędów w kwantowych circuit'ach odpornych na błędy i sposobów jej
kontrolowania. W szczególności omówię transwersal implementacje gate'ów, które oferują bardzo prosty sposób kontroli propagacji
błędów – choć istnieje fundamentalne ograniczenie uniemożliwiające wyłączne korzystanie z tej metody.
Opowiem też o innej metodologii, dotyczącej tak zwanych magicznych stanów, która oferuje inną ścieżkę kontroli propagacji
błędów w kwantowych circuit'ach odpornych na błędy – choć nie jest to jedyna znana metoda. Na koniec lekcja
kończy się dość ogólną dyskusją na temat twierdzenia o progu, o którym wspomniałem przed chwilą.
Twierdzenie to mówi, że arbitralnie duże kwantowe circuit'y mogą być implementowane w sposób niezawodny, o ile współczynnik błędów wszystkich składowych
jest poniżej pewnej skończonej wartości progowej. Ogólnie rzecz biorąc, ta wartość progowa
zależy od używanego kodu korekcji błędów oraz od konkretnych wyborów dotyczących odpornych implementacji
kwantowych gate'ów i pomiarów, ale nie od rozmiaru implementowanego circuit'u. To daje nam dobry powód, by wierzyć, że obliczenia kwantowe na dużą skalę
staną się kiedyś rzeczywistością. Zaczniemy od omówienia podstawowego modelu kwantowego obliczania odpornego na
błędy, który w sposób naturalny opiera się na kwantowych circuit'ach i kwantowych kodach korekcji błędów. Na potrzeby tej dyskusji
wyobraźmy sobie, że mamy kwantowy circuit, który chcemy zaimplementować – taki jak ten pokazany tutaj. Ten akurat
jest circuit'em teleportacji zawierającym preparację EBIT-a. Szczegóły nie mają jednak znaczenia dla tej dyskusji – możesz sobie wyobrazić, że
to dowolny inny kwantowy circuit, możliwie znacznie większy, obejmujący preparacje stanów, operacje unitarne
i pomiary. Ten circuit oczywiście reprezentuje ideał, a jego rzeczywista
implementacja nie będzie doskonała. Naturalne pytanie brzmi: co mogłoby pójść
nie tak? Cóż, może pójść nie tak całkiem sporo. Na przykład inicjalizacje stanów zazwyczaj nie będą
doskonałe. Oczywiście unitarne gate'y nie będą doskonałe, podobnie jak
pomiary. Co więcej, same qubity będą podatne na szumy, w tym dekohercję, w każdym momencie
obliczeń – nawet gdy nic się z nimi nie dzieje i po prostu przechowują informację kwantową. Innymi słowy, właściwie
wszystko może pójść nie tak. Jest jednak jeden wyjątek – przynajmniej takie jest typowe założenie –
i jest nim to, że wszelkie klasyczne obliczenia w tym procesie prawdopodobnie nie będą zawodne, bo dla wszelkich celów praktycznych
klasyczne obliczenia są w zasadzie doskonałe. Na przykład, jeśli uruchomimy klasyczny algorytm dopasowania, żeby
obliczać korekcje dla błędów surface code'u, naprawdę nie musimy martwić się o to, że te klasyczne obliczenia mogą zawieść. Ale cokolwiek bezpośrednio
obejmuje informację kwantową – może. Oczywiście potrzebujemy precyzyjnego modelu, przez który możemy powiązać
prawdopodobieństwa różnych zdarzeń. Jeśli chcemy, możemy stworzyć tak skomplikowany model, jak nam się podoba, aby jak najlepiej odzwierciedlić to, co
faktycznie dzieje się w rzeczywistości. Jeśli jednak model jest zbyt skomplikowany, może okazać się trudny lub niemożliwy w użyciu albo
niemożliwy do analizy. Jeden bardzo prosty przykład modelu szumów, który ludzie często rozważają,
to niezależny stochastyczny model szumów, w którym błędy lub awarie dotykające różne składowe w różnych
momentach – innymi słowy, w różnych miejscach circuit'u – są niezależne.
Na przykład możemy powiedzieć, że każdy gate psuje się z pewnym prawdopodobieństwem, że bit flipy i phase flipy zdarzają się przechowywanym qubitom z innym
prawdopodobieństwem na jednostkę czasu itd. Ale założenie jest takie, że między różnymi
błędami nie ma korelacji. Możesz sprzeciwić się temu modelowi, bo prawdopodobnie pewne korelacje między
błędami istnieje. Na przykład jest małe prawdopodobieństwo katastrofalnego błędu, który naraz niszczy wszystkie qubity.
A może bardziej prawdopodobne jest to, że mogą wystąpić błędy zlokalizowane, które jednak dotykają wielu składowych.
Nikt temu nie zaprzecza. Niemniej model ten stanowi prosty punkt wyjścia, który
w istocie reprezentuje ideę, że natura jest nieprzewidywalna, ale nie jest złośliwa i nie stara się celowo
psuć obliczeń kwantowych. Istnieją inne, można by rzec bardziej realistyczne modele szumów, które są często rozważane. Niezależnie od
wybranego modelu, jeśli okaże się, że nasz model wiedzie nas na manowce i dowiemy się czegoś nowego o błędach w
danym systemie, możemy naturalnie sformułować i rozważyć inne modele błędów. Następnie przyjrzymy się
podstawowej strategii implementowania kwantowych circuit'ów w sposób odporny na błędy. Rozważmy więc dany
logiczny circuit kwantowy, czyli idealny circuit kwantowy, który chcemy uruchomić. Na przykład możemy rozważyć ten sam circuit, co
poprzednio, który jest teraz nieco rozciągnięty, bo będziemy potrzebować trochę więcej miejsca na jego odporną na błędy implementację. Przede
wszystkim preparacje stanów, unitarne gate'y i pomiary nie będą wykonywane bezpośrednio jako pojedyncze gate'y ani jako
pojedyncze pomiary qubitów czy preparacje stanów, lecz będą realizowane przez tak zwane gadżety, które
mogą każdy zawierać wiele qubitów i wiele operacji. Na tym diagramie
zilustruję to, rysując fioletowe ramki wokół tych elementów. Możesz myśleć o tych fioletowych ramkach jak o małych circuit'ach lub operacjach, które są
jedynie oznaczone przez daną preparację stanu lub gate, który zamierzamy zaimplementować. Po drugie, musimy chronić
qubity za pomocą kodu korekcji błędów. Zatem to nie same logiczne qubity będą łączyć różne gadżety, lecz gadżety działają na
fizycznych qubitach kodujących te logiczne qubity. Warto tu podkreślić, że logiczne qubity, na których nam zależy,
nigdy nie są odkryte, co oznacza, że te logiczne qubity przez całe swoje istnienie będą chronione przez cokolwiek
kwantowego kodu korekcji błędów używamy. Na koniec wykonujemy korekcję błędów na zakodowanych qubitach
wielokrotnie w trakcie obliczeń, zasadniczo przy każdej nadarzającej się okazji. Jest to krytycznie ważne, abyśmy to robili.
Intuicyjnie mówiąc, gdy pojawiają się błędy, losowość lub niepewność zaczyna gromadzić się w stanie naszych
qubitów i musimy stale pracować nad usuwaniem tej losowości, czyli entropii. Właśnie to dzieje się przez korekcję błędów.
Można myśleć o tych krokach korekcji błędów jak o małych logicznych lodówkach lub pompach ciepła, które
pozwalają logicznym qubitom pozostać „zimne", by obliczenia mogły działać poprawnie.
Gdy wszystkie te wybory zostaną dokonane – czyli wybór gadżetów, kodu oraz przy założeniu konkretnego modelu szumów – pojawia się
fundamentalne pytanie, które możemy sobie zadać: czy to naprawdę pomaga? Czy jest lepiej, czy
może gorzej? Jeśli szumów jest za dużo, możemy wręcz pogarszać sytuację,
tak jak 9-qubitowy kod Shore'a pogarsza sprawę, gdy prawdopodobieństwo błędu jest zbyt wysokie.
Ale jeśli szumy są poniżej pewnego progu, cały ten dodatkowy wysiłek się opłaci. Jak omówimy pod koniec lekcji,
otwierają się wtedy możliwości dalszego zmniejszania błędu. W tej części lekcji omówimy propagację błędów w
kwantowych circuit'ach odpornych na błędy o podstawowej strukturze, którą właśnie opisałem. Okazuje się, że to jest
główna troska, bo jeśli nie uda nam się kontrolować propagacji błędów, błędy szybko przytłoczą nasze wysiłki korekcji
błędów. Ale jeśli uda nam się kontrolować propagację błędów, nasz kod będzie miał znacznie większą szansę
na nadążenie, tak że błędy mogą być korygowane wystarczająco szybko, by nasze obliczenia
działały. Punktem wyjścia dla tej dyskusji jest spostrzeżenie, że gate'y dwuqubitowe lub bardziej ogólnie – wieloqubitowe –
mogą propagować błędy nawet wtedy, gdy działają poprawnie.
Na przykład rozważmy gate C-NOT. Załóżmy, że błąd X występuje na kontrolnym qubicie przed wykonaniem gate'u C-NOT.
Cóż, błąd X działa jak gate X. I stwierdzamy, że
circuit po lewej jest równoważny temu po prawej, gdzie błędy X występują na obu qubitach po wykonaniu C-
NOT-a. To jest propagacja błędów, bo niefortunne położenie błędu X po lewej efektywnie zamienia go
w dwa błędy X po prawej. I nigdy tego nie obejdziemy. Tak długo, jak używamy gate'ów C-NOT, zawsze istnieje
szansa, że błąd X wystąpi na kontrolnym qubicie tuż przed nim, co następnie propaguje do dwóch błędów X
po jego wykonaniu. Ale jak zobaczymy, o ile podejmiemy kroki, by ograniczyć szkody, jakie to powoduje, będziemy w porządku. Przy okazji,
to samo zjawisko występuje, gdy mamy błąd Z na docelowym qubicie tuż przed C-NOT-em. Omówiliśmy to
wcześniej i możesz sprawdzić te równości, po prostu wykonując mnożenia, lub możesz to zweryfikować używając
Qiskit. Wniosek jest taki, że w obu przypadkach spowoduje to skorelowane błędy na wielu qubitach. Oczywiście
nie powinniśmy zapominać, że same gate'y C-NOT mogą też być zawodne, co również może powodować skorelowane
błędy. Dodając do naszych obaw – kolejne gate'y dwuqubitowe mogą propagować te błędy jeszcze dalej.
Na przykład jeśli mamy trzy gate'y C-NOT jak tutaj – tak jak to widzimy przy mierzeniu generatorów X-stabilizatora – to pojedynczy błąd może
szybko propagować do wielu qubitów. I jeśli to zdarzy się wewnątrz jednego bloku kodu – na przykład zestawu
qubitów kodujących razem logiczny qubit – wybrany przez nas kod korekcji błędów nie da rady,
ponieważ kody są projektowane do korekcji błędów małej wagi, a nie błędów dużej wagi jak te.
To jest coś, co musimy mieć na pierwszym planie w myślach, gdy zastanawiamy się nad gadżetami i
krokami korekcji błędów w kwantowych circuit'ach odpornych na błędy. Najprostszy znany sposób łagodzenia propagacji błędów w odpornych
na błędy kwantowych circuit'ach to transwersal implementacja gate'ów – wyjaśnię zaraz, co to oznacza.
Zostawmy więc na ekranie rysunek naszej odpornej na błędy implementacji circuit'u jako pomoc wizualną.
Chodzi o to, że dla niektórych kwantowych kodów korekcji błędów pewne gate'y mogą być implementowane transwersal, co
oznacza implementację za pomocą gadżetów będących iloczynami tensorowymi operacji, gdzie każda operacja działa tylko na
jednej pozycji qubitu w każdym bloku kodu. Najłatwiej to wyjaśnić na przykładach. Pierwszy i
prawdopodobnie najprostszy przykład to transwersal implementacje gate'ów Pauliego.
Chodzi o to, że chcemy zbudować gadżety dla każdego gate'u w naszym circuit'cie. We wszystkich przypadkach te gadżety
działają na blokach kodu, tak jak widzimy dla gate'ów X i Z na końcu naszego circuit'u teleportacji. Oczywiście
nie możemy dekodować, aplikować gate'u Pauliego i ponownie kodować, bo zostawiałoby to logiczny qubit niechroniony, a błędy
mogłyby propagować wewnątrz bloku kodu w wyniku ponownego kodowania.
Na szczęście nie musimy tego robić, o ile używamy kodu stabilizatora, ponieważ każdy kod stabilizatora pozwala na
bezpośrednie stosowanie operacji Pauliego na naszych logicznych qubitach. I w rzeczywistości możemy to zrobić za pomocą iloczynu tensorowego gate'ów Pauliego
na fizycznych qubitach użytych do kodowania.
Na przykład, rozważając surface code 3×3 z poprzedniej lekcji, możemy implementować gate'y X i Z na logicznym
qubicie zakodowanym przez ten kod, składając gate'y X i Z wraz z gate'ami identyczności we wzorcach
sugerowanych tutaj. To jest transwersal implementacja tych gate'ów, ponieważ każda z tych pojedynczych operacji gate'ów
działa tylko na jednej pozycji qubitu w każdym bloku kodu.
Używamy tu tylko jednobitowych gate'ów, więc w pewnym sensie jest to trywialne, ale w każdym razie gadżety tego rodzaju nie spowodują propagacji
błędów. Owszem, każdy z pojedynczych gate'ów w takim gadżecie może zawieść i spowoduje to
błędy, ale zawsze będziemy wykonywać korekcję błędów bezpośrednio po każdym gadżecie. I o ile współczynnik błędów jest
wystarczająco niski, kod korekcji błędów te błędy skoryguje.
I jak wspomniałem, jest to zawsze możliwe dla gate'ów Pauliego dla każdego kodu stabilizatora.
Choć musisz zidentyfikować odpowiedni wzorzec gate'ów Pauliego w gadżetach, by poprawnie zaimplementować wybraną logiczną operację Pauliego.
Dla kolejnego przykładu, który dotyczy gate'ów dwubitowych – tym razem możemy rozważyć transwersal implementacje
gate'ów C-NOT. W szczególności, dla każdego kodu CSS możemy zawsze implementować gate C-NOT
między dwoma logicznymi qubitami, po prostu wykonując gate'y C-NOT na odpowiadających parach fizycznych
qubitów. To spełnia warunek bycia transwersal, ponieważ każdy z tych pojedynczych gate'ów C-NOT działa tylko
na jednej pozycji qubitu w każdym bloku kodu. Na przykład pierwszy gate C-NOT działa tylko na najwyższym qubicie
w każdym bloku kodu, drugi gate C-NOT działa tylko na drugim od góry qubicie i tak
dalej. W tym przypadku może dochodzić do propagacji błędów, bo gate'y C-NOT propagują błędy i nie ma
sposobu, by temu zapobiec. Ale kluczem jest to, że propagacja błędów nigdy nie zachodzi wewnątrz jednego bloku kodu. Na przykład
błąd X może wystąpić na górnym qubicie górnego bloku kodu tuż przed wykonaniem gadżetu i pierwszy C-NOT
w gadżecie propaguje ten błąd do górnego qubitu w dolnym bloku. Ale dwa powstałe błędy są
teraz w oddzielnych blokach kodu. Zatem kroki korekcji błędów po gadżecie będą w stanie skorygować te błędy indywidualnie, ponieważ
te błędy dotykają tylko jednego qubitu w każdym bloku kodu.
Dla kontrastu, gdyby propagacja błędów zachodziła wewnątrz tego samego bloku kodu, moglibyśmy mieć problem, bo
propagacja błędów zamieniałaby wtedy błąd małej wagi w błąd wyższej wagi, którego nasz kod może nie być w stanie obsłużyć.
Ta implementacja nie działa dla kodów nie-CSS, ale o ile używamy kodu CSS, możemy zawsze transwersal implementować gate'y C-NOT
w ten sposób. I jeszcze jeden przykład: każdy
gate Clifforda może być implementowany transwersal dla kodu Steane'a. A właściwie dla dowolnego kodu kolorów, co jest jedną z naprawdę miłych cech kodów
kolorów. W szczególności gate Hadamard na logicznym qubicie może być implementowany przez wykonanie gate'ów Hadamard indywidualnie na
każdym z fizycznych qubitów, a logiczny gate S może być implementowany nie przez gate S na każdym qubicie, lecz przez gate
S† na każdym fizycznym qubicie. Wniosek jest więc taki, że transwersal implementacje gate'ów są z natury
odporne na błędy, ponieważ nigdy nie propagują błędów wewnątrz jednego bloku kodu, co daje krokom korekcji błędów szansę na korekcję
wszelkich błędów wprowadzonych lub propagowanych przez gate'y używane w tych gadżetach. To świetnie i jest to
naprawdę prosty sposób budowania gadżetów odpornych na błędy. Istnieją różne kody pozwalające na transwersal implementacje różnych gate'ów –
na przykład gate'ów T – ale niestety jest niemożliwe, by jakikolwiek nietrywialny kod implementował
transwersal uniwersalny zestaw gate'ów, co jest faktem zwanym twierdzeniem Eastina-Knilla. Mówiąc bardziej technicznie,
stwierdza ono, że o ile nasz kod ma odległość co najmniej dwa, zbiór gate'ów możliwych do implementacji transwersal będzie koniecznie generować
dyskretny zbiór operacji z dokładnością do globalnej fazy, a zatem ten zbiór nie jest uniwersalny, bo universalne zestawy gate'ów
koniecznie generują nieskończenie wiele operacji. Nie będę wyjaśniać dowodu tego twierdzenia, który korzysta z pewnych
podstawowych faktów o grupach Liego i algebrach Liego – nie są one wymagane dla tej serii. Ale podstawowy pomysł jest
taki, że nieskończone rodziny operacji transwersal nie mogą utrzymać nas wewnątrz przestrzeni kodu, ponieważ drobne
różnice w operacjach transwersal są dobrze przybliżane przez operacje Pauliego małej wagi, które kod wykrywa jako
błędy. Jesteśmy więc bardzo zadowoleni, gdy możemy transwersal implementować gate'y. Ale niezależnie od wybranego kodu, wiemy, że
zawsze będziemy mieć pewne gate'y, których w ten sposób nie możemy implementować. Musimy więc szukać alternatywnych gadżetów. Zgodnie z
twierdzeniem Eastina-Knilla wiemy, że nie jest możliwe transwersal implementowanie uniwersalnego zestawu kwantowych gate'ów, nawet
dla skromnego kodu korekcji błędów o odległości 2. Musimy więc znaleźć inne sposoby odpornej na błędy implementacji gate'ów
– przynajmniej dla niektórych gate'ów. Jednym ze znanych sposobów jest użycie tak zwanych magicznych
stanów. Na potrzeby tej dyskusji przypomnijmy sobie gate'y S i T, które są
jednobitowymi gate'ami zdefiniowanymi tak jak pokazano tutaj na ekranie. Zauważmy też, że po pierwsze, S jest operacją Clifforda
– co wynika z naszej definicji operacji Clifforda. Możesz też sprawdzić, że sprzęganie macierzy Pauliego przez S zawsze daje nam plus lub minus inną
macierz Pauliego. Po drugie, T nie jest operacją Clifforda. I w rzeczywistości, jeśli połączymy T z Hadamardem i C-NOT-em, oboma
będącymi operacjami Clifforda, otrzymujemy uniwersalny zestaw kwantowych gate'ów. Zatem nie możemy implementować gate'u T
używając samych operacji Clifforda i pomiarów w standardowej bazie. Ale możemy w rzeczywistości implementować gate T przy użyciu
operacji Clifforda i pomiarów w standardowej bazie, jeśli dodatkowo dysponujemy kopią stanu pokazanego tutaj na
ekranie – czyli gate T zastosowanego do stanu plus.
Ten stan nazywa się magicznym stanem, choć nie jest jedynym tego rodzaju.
Termin „magiczny stan" jest też używany do określania różnych stanów pełniących podobną rolę do tego w wariantach całego tego
schematu. Na przykład ten pokazany tutaj circuit wykonuje to zadanie. I nie jest zbyt trudno to
sprawdzić. Oto stan początkowy z górnym układem po prawej. Jeśli zastosujemy gate C-NOT i uprościmy, otrzymamy
stan pokazany tutaj.
Jeśli więc zmierzymy dolny qubit i otrzymamy zero – co dzieje się z prawdopodobieństwem 1/2 – nie wykonujemy
gate'u S i wyjściem jest T zastosowane do s.
I jeśli zmierzymy jeden – co oczywiście też dzieje się z prawdopodobieństwem 1/2 – stosujemy gate S, a wynik netto jest
taki, że wyjściem znów jest T zastosowane do s. Nawiasem mówiąc, to nie jedyny sposób to zrobić. Istnieją inne podobne
circuit'y, które wykonują to samo zadanie, ale jest to jeden ze sposobów.
To jest nieco uproszczony przykład czegoś zwanego kwantową teleportacją gate'ów, o której wspominałem w lekcji 4, gdzie teleportacja jest używana
nie do przesyłania qubitów, lecz do stosowania gate'ów. Połączenie z teleportacją może nie być tu w pełni klarowne, bo jak
powiedziałem, to jest uproszczona wersja, z której możemy skorzystać, ponieważ T jest diagonalny. Ale jeśli chcesz
dowiedzieć się więcej, kluczowe słowa to: kwantowa teleportacja gate'ów.
Moglibyśmy też zrobić coś podobnego, żeby implementować gate S, gdzie tym razem jedyne potrzebne gate'y to C-NOT i gate Z oraz pomiar –
co jest pomocne, gdy nie mamy transwersal implementacji gate'u S. To jest interesujące, ale nie jest
do końca jasne, czy to naprawdę pomaga. Na przykład w przypadku implementacji gate'u T
udaje nam się zastosować gate T do stanu wejściowego. Ale żeby to zrobić, zdaje się, że stosujemy gate T do stanu plus, by otrzymać
magiczny stan. Sytuacja jest podobna dla implementacji gate'u S. Chodzi o to, że niekoniecznie
musimy najpierw tworzyć stan plus, a następnie stosować gate T, by uzyskać magiczny stan. Istnieją inne możliwe sposoby uzyskania tego stanu. I
w szczególności możemy to zrobić bez martwienia się o propagację błędów w obliczeniach, które przeprowadzamy, ponieważ magiczne stany mogą być tworzone
oddzielnie. To umożliwia odporną na błędy implementację gate'u T, co teraz krótko opiszę.
Po pierwsze, nie będziemy faktycznie uruchamiać prostego circuit'u dwuqubitowego pokazanego tutaj, lecz zamiast tego uruchomimy ten circuit przy użyciu
qubitów zakodowanych w cokolwiek kodu korekcji błędów używamy do naszej odpornej na błędy implementacji. Oznacza to, że
unitarne gate'y i pomiary są wykonywane przez odporne na błędy gadżety. A to znaczy, że potrzebujemy też naszych
magicznych stanów w zakodowanej formie. Zatem wszystko będzie odporne na błędy, o ile zdołamy zdobyć
zakodowane magiczne stany. Przyjmujemy tutaj nawiasem mówiąc, że mamy już odporny na błędy gadżet dla gate'u S. Jeśli
używalibyśmy kodu Steane'a, moglibyśmy po prostu transwersal implementować gate S. A dla kodów, dla których to nie działa, jedną z opcji jest
użycie całego tego schematu do odpornej na błędy implementacji gate'u S, a następnie użycie tej implementacji tutaj.
Choć nie jest to jedyna opcja. Ale wracając do implementacji – ważne pytanie, które pozostaje, to: jak zdołamy zdobyć
zakodowany magiczny stan, skoro nie mamy jeszcze odpornej na błędy implementacji gate'u T, by to
uprościć? I kluczową ideą jest to, że możemy użyć procesu probabilistycznego do tworzenia zakodowanych magicznych stanów. I jeśli
akurat się nie uda, to nic – możemy po prostu odrzucić nieudane próby i spróbować ponownie.
I to nie zakłóca obliczeń, które faktycznie staramy się wykonać, ponieważ tworzenie magicznych stanów odbywa się
oddzielnie. Typowy sposób, w jaki się to robi, to proces zwany destylacją magicznych stanów. I działa tak:
mamy pewien circuit zwany destylatorem. Na wejście tego destylatora podajemy kolekcję zaszumionych magicznych
stanów, a następnie mierzymy wszystkie poza jednym z wyjść. I jeśli uwarunkujemy na tym, że wszystkie wyniki pomiaru wynoszą zero,
to co wychodzi, to mniej zaszumiony magiczny stan, który może następnie być jednym z qubitów na wejściu
kolejnego destylatora. I proces trwa, dopóki albo nie zawiedzie, bo jeden z wyników pomiaru jest niezerowy i próbujemy ponownie, albo mamy magiczny
stan wystarczająco wysokiej jakości, by bezpiecznie użyć go do implementacji gate'u T w obliczeniach, na których nam zależy.
Istnieją różne znane sposoby budowania takiego destylatora, ale wszystkie działają zasadniczo tak samo: są dekoderami kodów stabilizatora,
czyli odwrotnościami circuit'ów kodujących, co jest miłe, bo oznacza, że destylator może być operacją
Clifforda. Wreszcie, ten proces destylacji faktycznie zachodzi na poziomie logicznych qubitów. Zatem w rzeczywistości
wszystko jest wykonywane za pomocą gadżetów dla destylatora i pomiarów. Ten proces musi
gdzieś się zacząć. Ale o ile współczynnik szumów nie jest zbyt wysoki, możliwe jest tworzenie zaszumionych, ale wystarczająco dobrych
magicznych stanów do jego uruchomienia. Na przykład przez zastosowanie faktycznego zaszumionego gate'u T do qubitu w stanie plus, a następnie
zakodowanie tego qubitu. To był bardzo ogólny opis, ale mam nadzieję, że dałem ci ogólne pojęcie o tym, jak to działa.
Jest to znacznie bardziej skomplikowane niż transwersal implementowanie gate'ów, ale jednak oferuje sposób implementowania universalnego zestawu kwantowych
gate'ów w sposób odporny na błędy, czego same transwersal implementacje gate'ów nie mogą zapewnić. Czasem twierdzi się,
że narzut związany z używaniem magicznych stanów do odpornej na błędy implementacji gate'ów tą drogą byłby bardzo wysoki,
a zdecydowana większość pracy szłaby na destylację magicznych stanów, podczas gdy samo wykonywanie właściwych obliczeń stałoby się czymś
drugorzędnym. Ale tak naprawdę nie jest to wcale takie oczywiste i przeprowadzono szczegółowe analizy, które ujawniają, że ta metoda
może być w praktyce realna. Istnieje kilka innych znanych schematów odpornej na błędy implementacji gate'ów. Deformacja kodu i przełączanie kodu to nazwy
powiązane z niektórymi z tych schematów, a nowe sposoby są nadal opracowywane i udoskonalane, ale nie opiszę tych
metod w tej lekcji. Istnieje jeszcze jedna ważna kwestia dotycząca odpornych na błędy implementacji kwantowych circuit'ów, i
dotyczy ona samych kroków korekcji błędów. Chodzi więc nie o implementowanie gate'ów, lecz o
samą korekcję błędów. Problem polega na tym, że jeśli pomyślimy o prostych circuit'ach, które
widzieliśmy po raz pierwszy w lekcji 14, do mierzenia generatorów stabilizatora metodą estymacji fazy, to stwierdzimy, że same w sobie nie są
odporne na błędy, ponieważ potencjalnie mogłyby powodować propagację błędów wewnątrz jednego bloku kodu.
Wracamy tu do idei, że cokolwiek obejmuje informację kwantową, jest podatne na błędy, a to obejmuje circuit'y, które same w sobie mają
korygować błędy. Wydaje się to dość problematyczne, ale istnieje kilka znanych rozwiązań tego problemu. Wspomnę tylko kilka z
nich, choć nie wyjaśnię żadnego szczegółowo. Nawiasem mówiąc, jeśli nabierasz przekonania, że kwantowe obliczenia odporne na błędy są
skomplikowane i jest wiele szczegółów do rozważenia, to jest to zrozumiałe, bo to prawda. Jest tu wiele ruchomych części
i moim zamiarem w tej lekcji jest nie wyjaśnianie wszystkich szczegółów, lecz jedynie danie ci podstawowego wprowadzenia do tego, jak to wszystko
działa. Jedną z metod kwantowej korekcji błędów odpornej na błędy jest metoda korekcji błędów Shore'a, nazwana na cześć Petera
Shore'a, który jako pierwszy ją zaproponował. Polega ona na wykonywaniu każdego pomiaru syndromu za pomocą tak zwanego stanu kota,
który jest tym samym co stan GHZ dla trzech qubitów, ale może być uogólniony na dowolną liczbę qubitów odpowiadającą wadze generatora stabilizatora,
który zamierzamy zmierzyć. W szczególności circuit pokazany tutaj sprawdza się do mierzenia generatora stabilizatora. I można
wykazać, że ta metoda nie powoduje propagacji błędów wewnątrz bloku kodu.
Wymaga tworzenia samego stanu kota. I żeby działała niezawodnie w obliczu błędów i potencjalnie zawodnych gate'ów, metoda faktycznie
wymaga wielokrotnego uruchamiania takich circuit'ów i wyciągania wniosków o tym, gdzie różne błędy mogły wystąpić w trakcie
procesu. Alternatywna metoda to korekcja błędów Steane'a, po raz pierwszy zaproponowana przez Andrew Steane'a, i ta
metoda działa inaczej i sprawdza się tylko dla kodów CSS. W tej metodzie nie wykonujemy faktycznie pomiarów syndromu na zakodowanych stanach kwantowych
w circuit'cie, który staramy się uruchomić, lecz zamiast tego celowo propagujemy błędy do systemu przestrzeni roboczej,
a następnie mierzymy ten system i klasycznie wykrywamy błędy. Ten rysunek pokazuje, jak to robić dla błędów X, gdzie qubity przestrzeni roboczej
są początkowo ustawione na kodowanie stanu plus. Jest to więc zasadniczo
transwersal implementacja gate'u C-NOT, która powinna nic nie robić, bo cel jest w stanie plus. Ale jeśli
byłyby błędy X w górnych qubitach, propagują się w dół do dolnego systemu i zostaną wykryte. Istnieje też podobna metoda wykrywania błędów Z,
której tutaj nie pokazano. Istnieje też pokrewna metoda zwana korekcją błędów Knilla, po raz pierwszy zaproponowana przez Manny'ego Knilla,
która opiera się na teleportacji zamiast transwersal C-NOT i pozwala jej działać dla dowolnych kodów stabilizatora,
nie tylko kodów CSS.
Ostatnią rzeczą, którą omówię w tej lekcji, jest bardzo ważne twierdzenie zwane twierdzeniem o progu. Oto nieco nieformalne
sformułowanie tego twierdzenia. Mówi ono, że jeśli mamy dowolny circuit kwantowy z n gate'ami, gdzie n może być dowolnie duże, to
możliwe jest zaimplementowanie tego circuit'u z dużą dokładnością przy użyciu zaszumionego circuit'u kwantowego, pod warunkiem że poziom szumów
jest poniżej pewnej wartości progowej niezależnej od n. Co więcej, nie jest to zbyt kosztowne –
rozmiar wymaganego zaszumionego circuit'u jest rzędu n razy pewna stała potęga logarytmu
z n. Bardziej formalne sformułowanie twierdzenia wymaga sprecyzowania modelu szumów, czego nie zrobię w tej lekcji.
Można na przykład udowodnić je dla niezależnego stochastycznego modelu szumów, o którym wspomniałem wcześniej, gdzie błędy pojawiają się
niezależnie w każdym możliwym miejscu circuit'u z pewnym prawdopodobieństwem ściśle mniejszym od tej wartości progowej. Ale można też
udowodnić je dla bardziej ogólnych modeli szumów, w których mogą istnieć korelacje między błędami. Jest to wynik
teoretyczny i typowy sposób, w jaki się go dowodzi, niekoniecznie przekłada się na coś, co faktycznie robilibyśmy w praktyce, ale jest to mimo wszystko
bardzo ważne twierdzenie w sensie praktycznym. A powodem jest to, że zasadniczo mówi, że nie ma żadnej fundamentalnej bariery dla wykonywania
obliczeń kwantowych przy użyciu zaszumionych składowych.
Jeśli tylko współczynnik błędów tych składowych jest poniżej tej wartości progowej, mogą być one używane do budowania niezawodnych kwantowych circuit'ów o dowolnym
rozmiarze. Inaczej mówiąc, gdyby twierdzenie nie było prawdziwe, trudno sobie wyobrazić, żeby obliczenia kwantowe na dużą skalę
kiedykolwiek stały się rzeczywistością. W formalnych dowodach tego twierdzenia jest wiele szczegółów technicznych, których nie będę
przekazywać. Ale postaram się wyjaśnić podstawową ideę na wysokim poziomie. Postaram się też luźno powiązać tę podstawową
ideę z tym, czego można by się spodziewać w praktyce. Załóżmy więc, że to jest nasz circuit. To ten sam circuit, o którym
mówiliśmy przez całą lekcję. Ale znów możemy sobie wyobrazić, że nasz circuit jest znacznie większy i bardziej skomplikowany niż ten. Chcemy
zaimplementować ten circuit, ale wszystkie nasze składowe są zaszumione. I zakładając, że używamy niezależnego stochastycznego modelu szumów
tylko dla uproszczenia, istnieje pewne prawdopodobieństwo P, z jakim błędy pojawiają się niezależnie w każdym możliwym miejscu.
Jeśli circuit byłby znacznie większy niż odwrotność tego prawdopodobieństwa P, moglibyśmy być dość pewni, że
jego bezpośrednia implementacja nie działałaby poprawnie. Przechodzimy więc przez całą procedurę odpornej na błędy implementacji circuit'u,
jak dotąd omawiałem, i zadajemy sobie pytanie, które postawiłem wcześniej: czy jest lepiej, czy
może gorzej? Cóż, jeśli prawdopodobieństwo P reprezentujące prawdopodobieństwo błędu dla każdej składowej jest zbyt duże, to
to nie pomoże – tak jak 9-qubitowy kod Shore'a nie pomaga, gdy prawdopodobieństwo błędu przekracza około 3 i 3/4%.
W szczególności sprawiliśmy, że circuit jest teraz większy. Zatem jest o wiele więcej miejsc, gdzie błędy mogą uderzyć.
Jednak jeśli P jest wystarczająco małe, to pomoże. I w efekcie zredukujemy prawdopodobieństwo błędu
dla obliczeń logicznych, które wykonujemy. Przyjrzyjmy się temu
trochę bardziej szczegółowo. I żeby zobaczyć główne idee w jak najprostszym możliwym scenariuszu, załóżmy, że używamy 7-qubitowego kodu Steane'a do korekcji
błędów, który pozwala na korekcję do jednego błędu na blok kodu. Zatem żeby wystąpił błąd logiczny
w oryginalnym circuit'cie, musimy mieć co najmniej dwa błędy w tym samym bloku kodu w naszej odpornej
na błędy implementacji.
Mając na uwadze, że jest wiele różnych sposobów na to, by dwa lub więcej błędów znalazło się w tym samym bloku kodu, można argumentować, że prawdopodobieństwo błędu logicznego
w każdym miejscu oryginalnego circuit'u wynosi co najwyżej C × P^2, gdzie C jest liczbą zależną od kodu i od
użytych gadżetów. Ale co ważne, nie zależy od rozmiaru oryginalnego circuit'u.
Zatem jeśli P jest mniejsze od odwrotności C – liczby, którą możemy przyjąć jako naszą wartość progową – to
przekłada się to na redukcję błędu. Nasza ciężka praca przy odpornej na błędy implementacji circuit'u przynosi
efekty. Jednak ten nowy współczynnik błędów może wciąż być zbyt wysoki, by cały circuit działał poprawnie. Musimy więc
zrobić więcej. W praktyce naturalnym działaniem w tym miejscu jest wybór lepszego kodu i lepszych gadżetów, by obniżyć współczynnik
błędów do punktu, gdzie implementacja prawdopodobnie zadziała.
Teoretycznie prostym sposobem argumentowania, że jest to możliwe, jest konkatenacja. Innymi słowy,
myślimy o odpornej na błędy implementacji oryginalnego circuit'u jako o nowym logicznym circuit'cie. A następnie implementujemy go odpornie
na błędy. I robimy to znów i znów, tyle razy, ile potrzeba. I okazuje się, że to szybko redukuje
błąd. I właśnie tak twierdzenie o progu jest typowo dowodzone na papierze.
Dam ci tylko bardzo zgrubne pojęcie o tym, jak spada współczynnik błędów, pomijając wiele szczegółów technicznych potrzebnych do
formalnego dowodu. Zaczynamy od prawdopodobieństwa błędu P dla naszych oryginalnych składowych. I jeśli implementujemy
circuit odpornie na błędy, błąd zmniejsza się o czynnik C × P. Jeśli następnie potraktujemy naszą odporną na błędy
implementację jako logiczny circuit i zaimplementujemy go odpornie na błędy, uzyskamy podobną redukcję współczynnika błędów. Ale
jeśli pomyślimy o efektywnym współczynniku błędów dla oryginalnego circuit'u, stwierdzimy, że spada on jeszcze dalej, bo teraz
zastępujemy współczynnik błędów P przez C × P^2, bo taki jest efektywny współczynnik błędów po pierwszym poziomie odpornej na błędy
implementacji. Konkretnie, po odrobinie algebry stwierdzamy, że błąd spada do CP
do sześcianu × P. A jeśli zrobimy to ponownie, mamy współczynnik błędów CP^7 × P. I jeśli
kontynuujemy przez łącznie K poziomów, okazuje się, że błąd maleje podwójnie wykładniczo w K. Zatem
nie musimy tego robić zbyt wiele razy, by współczynnik błędów stał się ekstremalnie mały.
Tymczasem circuit'y rosną w rozmiarze, ale rozmiar rośnie tylko jednostronnie wykładniczo w K, bo przy każdym
poziomie odporności na błędy rozmiar naszego circuit'u rośnie co najwyżej o czynnik określony przez maksymalny rozmiar
naszych gadżetów. I gdy to wszystko jest złożone razem i dokonano odpowiedniego wyboru liczby
poziomów konkatenacji, otrzymujemy twierdzenie o progu. Ale jak już sugerowałem, jest wiele szczegółów wymaganych, by to sformalizować. Jaka jest więc ta wartość progowa w rzeczywistości? Cóż, zależy od kodu i od gadżetów –
dla kodu Steane'a wraz z destylacją magicznych stanów jest ona znikoma i prawdopodobnie nieosiągalna
w praktyce. Ale używając surface code'ów i najnowocześniejszych gadżetów, szacuje się ją na około 1%. Co nie jest
złe. I w miarę odkrywania nowych kodów i metod możemy rozsądnie spodziewać się jej wzrostu, podczas gdy jednocześnie
poziom szumów w budowanych przez nas składowych będzie maleć. Dotarcie do punktu, w którym
obliczenia kwantowe na dużą skalę będzie można implementować odpornie na błędy, nie będzie łatwe i nie stanie się to z dnia na dzień.
Ale to twierdzenie w połączeniu z postępami w kwantowych kodach i w sprzęcie kwantowym, których dotąd byliśmy świadkami,
daje nam optymizm potrzebny do dalszego parcia naprzód ku ostatecznemu celowi, jakim jest zbudowanie
komputera kwantowego odpornego na błędy na dużą skalę. I to jest koniec lekcji i koniec serii.
Szczerze mam nadzieję, że seria była dla ciebie wartościowa, a jeśli tak, rozważ polecenie jej koledze lub przyjacielowi.
Koniecznie też zajrzyj do IBM Quantum Learning po dodatkowe kursy i tutoriale, i subskrybuj kanał Qiskit
na YouTube, jeśli jeszcze tego nie zrobiłeś, żeby być na bieżąco z naszymi przyszłymi materiałami. Dziękuję za
oglądanie.